traqué c'est de l'anglais pour dire du
suivi en gros c'est un petit boîtier on
appelle tracker ou boîtier gps ce
tracker y en a par ailleurs et c'est lui
qui va nous transmettre les données de
suivi donc de tracking pour chacune des
yoles pour le web ça sera comme un
google maps avec dessus en plus des
petites icônes de chacun des bateaux
plus un classement
le dispositif internet lui va permettre
à n'importe quelle personne avec une
connexion à palettes à pouvoir voir la
course
regardez ce qui intéresse le premier le
deuxième le troisième ou quatrième en
même temps avant les classements et les
temps de passage à chaque point
géographique du parcours on dispose ici
telle est l avantage est l'ajout que ça
apporte
c'est que grâce à notre système on peut
avoir du déclassement en temps réel
constamment pendant toute la course pour
les écarts en distance exacte entre
chacune des yoles et avoir des points de
vue que les caméras ne peuvent pas nous
produire parce qu'avec le virtuel on a
la possibilité d'avoir le point de vue
notre choix